you're working in australia so what what
are you working on
i am working on baslerman's uh movie
about elvis presley austin butler is
playing elvis presley and here let me
show you
let me show you the horrible haircut i
have to have
in order to portray colonel tom parker
check out check out this horrible okay
do you see that
look at that thing wait wait wait sit
[Applause]
[Music]
down
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what i really want to do is just have a
little tuft of hair right here
and then a big big beard and then
everybody would think i'm graham norton
yes it's uncanny you can play me in the
biopic
well now i i'm evidently that's my gig
now so i only play real people in show
[Music]
business